and it was this beautiful moment this
epiphany of like it is up and down on
the way up when you pan out you see that
your trajectory is in fact heading in
the right direction you are moving you
are making gains but if you zoom in you
will see this on your statistics it
looks up it looks down and in the moment
when things are sliding it just feels
like everything is falling apart but i
want you to be able to pan out and look
at the big vision and if you're just
starting can you trust that this is a
minor dip and an otherwise upward trend
so just staying committed to your
mission and your vision and keep moving
is getting a hundred thousand
subscribers one of your youtube goals
did you write it out on your goals for
this year or are you like me that when
you got started you thought that that
goal was too big and too scary well on
today's episode i am so excited to bring
you two powerful women who have already
reached that goal of a hundred thousand
subscribers and they're going to be
breaking down seven things they learned
along the journey of getting there my
name is heather torres and i am your
host of the think media podcast the
number one podcast to help you grow your
influence on youtube and then turn that
influence into a high impact and a high
income online business and i am so
excited for all of our new listeners
here on the podcast we are growing and i
want to say welcome make sure you
subscribe wherever you're listening to
this content so you can get all of the
videos and all of the audio that we have
for you now over on our youtube channel
we post several videos a week there so
make sure that you are subscribed on our
youtube channel as well
now today we're going to be getting into
these seven things that these two
entrepreneurs have learned in growing
their youtube channel but i want to
point out that one of the things that
both of these entrepreneurs did to not
just grow their youtube channel but to
grow their online business and income
was starting online courses now today's
video is in partnership with one of our
favorite course hosting platforms
thinkific whether you have a channel
about cooking guitar teaching business
coaching or fitness youtube creators all
share something in common a desire to
reach more viewers and make a bigger
impact without trading their time for
money so how do you do that by creating
an online course with a platform like
thinkific more than 50 000 course
creators have already used thinkific to
build their revenue and educate students
worldwide you can try thinkific today
for free at createwiththink.com now this
interview is from our annual conference
grow with video live this is a
conference we host every single year and
this year it's back in person in las
vegas in may of 2022. now this interview
was one that i conducted so i'm
referencing some different things that
were taught during that conference but
the meat of it of what they're teaching
is so important i love when nicole and
lauren really dig into their stories
about what they had to persevere through
and how they grew their channels to what
they are today so i'm excited for you to
jump into today's featured interview
let's head over and jump right to the
interview
[Music]
well welcome back and i am so excited
for this panel today i have two amazing
women of youtube sean already alluded a
little bit of their story but today
we're gonna be actually talking about
the seven things they learned from
reaching 100 000 subscribers let me know
in the chat do you want to reach 100 000
subscribers is that one of your goals
that you would like to do well let's
jump into this session and first off i
have lauren bateman let me tell you a
little bit about her as a childhood
cancer survivor lauren bateman knows the
importance of living in the moment
that's why at the age of 27 lauren quit
her cushy job as a research scientist to
pursue a career in music when lauren was
16 her very own mother told her sister
not to buy lauren a guitar because she
would waste it lauren decided she was
going to teach herself how to play
guitar on her own in 2010 lauren decided
to give a shot at entrepreneurship and
started teaching voice and guitar
lessons out of a spay out of a spare
bedroom in her small apartment near
boston massachusetts she was
absolutely she had absolutely zero
teaching experience
but knew
what she needed to do to make it work
her uh her popularity as a guitar
teacher grew locally until her schedule
was bursting at the seams man if you are
a content creator who's helping people
you might feel that right now uh lauren
now operates two music schools outside
of bost outside of the boston area in
the hopes of helping students of all
ages discover the joy and happiness of
music so lauren i'm so excited that
you're here today how you doing
hey how's it going thanks for having me
oh my gosh i also i always love seeing
your setup because you always have these
little hidden gems behind you
it's my personality corner that's what i
call it
so much fun and lauren thank you so much
for being uh here at gross video live
and interacting in the app so many
people were like lauren's here so it's
so fun that you're actually a part of
the conference this year um and i can't
wait to get into some more of uh your
journey now let me introduce nicole
nicole i also consider an amazing friend
a nicole is a parenting and soul-lining
mentor who helps women build a legacy
for themselves and their families by
showing them what is possible when they
are no longer when they no longer have
to choose between the two she's helped
millions of women in their parenting
journey and continues to redefine what
it means to be a conscious mom and a
powerhouse nicole how you doing hey
heather so happy to be here i'm doing
great thank you my goodness i'm so
excited that you're here and your set
looks amazing also not how you started
though right nicole
not at all this is years in the making
years in the making
so awesome well hey let's jump right
into um to today's session and i
actually asked them to submit ahead of
time uh things that they have learned
i've distilled them down into seven and
then of course i have two bonus ones for
you because they had such great tips for
you but nicole you said your one of the
uh lessons that you learned was that the
more real you are the deeper the impact
i talked a little bit about this on
stage and the last session but i'd love
to go deeper into that nicole what does
that actually mean to you and kind of
your journey on youtube with that
yeah
you know for me personally it's of
course been the journey of feeling safe
to really be my most authentic self and
it's taken years to get to that point
but what the lesson was in showing up as
the most authentic version of me is that
i build the most beautiful relationships
with people when
i am secure and safe in just being all
of me so i find that the youtube journey
has been really about building these
relationships i call them soul scribers
now right these are people who have
watched some of my videos since i was
pregnant with kai or kai was a newborn
and kai is now five and a half years old
and and these people in these
relationships follow you well beyond
youtube they follow you on other
platforms and outside of youtube and so
it's just been this beautiful evolution
of relationship building and that really
happens those deep connections happen
when you are your most authentic self
yeah and lauren did you experience this
at all because you come from a
non-traditional background when it comes
to music right it wasn't like something
you just you went to school for you
actually didn't go to school for this at
all you're really self-taught um have
you experienced that the more real you
are the more you show up as just you and
teach the things you love to teach that
you've seen explosive growth from that
yeah definitely i mean for me the
biggest thing like when you watch some
of my first videos you can see like i'm
really awkward and you know i'm like
stumbling over my words or i'm saying
the wrong words at the wrong time and i
think in the beginning we're so focused
on like what we should be or what we
think we should be and we focus on what
other people are doing that we forget
what we're trying to do and you know
once you get into those videos you know
10 20 30 videos deep more of you and
your personality comes out and that's
what people want that's what people want
to connect with is is the true you not
not the version of you that you think
you should be um
i love that so much lauren and man i
feel like this is like the the
explanation point to the talk that i
just gave so i love that you both have
experienced that as well now one of the
points lauren submitted was that good
content will always trump the video
quality lauren talk about your journey
in creating content over the years and
how you've really seen this be true
yeah so my first videos were just done
with the phone i didn't have a fancy
camera i didn't have the fancy lighting
i was doing a lot of things just based
off of like what i knew about filming
which was absolutely zero so i was like
well i'll just get a little tripod
actually i didn't even have a tripod i
was like putting my phone on a music
stand and it was like i was shooting
from below and weird angles all the
stuff they told you not to do yesterday
that's what i did when i started off but
you know one of my first videos that i
recorded i think it was june 2017
two years later a little over two years
later october 2019 that video was the
first video that got ranked in youtube
and it's funny because if you go back
and look at it's like this grainy video
it's dark but people loved the content
that i was delivering so it just goes to
show in that video you know sean talks
about videos he he recorded 10 years ago
still getting views that video still
gets me views and subscribers you know
four years later and it's just a really
dark grainy video but the content is
amazing and that's what people connected
with so just like you were saying press
record don't worry about don't sweat the
small stuff just press record yeah and
nicole you've experienced this as well
um some of your most viral videos were
literally you just shooting on you know
location basically or shooting just your
baby doing certain activities talk about
this for you it really is the the the
content over the video quality of what
you're producing
oh yeah i mean you know basic camera
the window light it was enough you know
and and my audio was kind of shoddy
b-roll was interesting and i'll even say
just to add to this point it happens
even later so i moved i moved i have a
new home and it took me a while to
figure out the lighting situation in
here and if you even go back and look a
couple months back in my vid like recent
you'll be like that that lighting isn't
quite right but i didn't let it stop me
i kept filming and i was like let me
figure out the equipment in this new
space as i go so it's always a journey
ooh that's a really good one too because
you're right i mean when you move
different seasons of life you're in a
new location maybe you're normally
filming in the daytime but now you have
to film at night time all of those
pieces come into effect but the video
quality
out trumps the actual production quality
of what you are doing this one was great
too lauren says learn how to do real
research for videos and content and that
actually is very important to getting to
100 000 subscribers talk about this
lauren and how you've discovered some
videos that mo people wouldn't think
would be the ones that would actually
become the famous videos or the viral
videos
yeah so you know when i first started
obviously i'm just recording and i'm
like well i should do a video on this or
i think i should do a video on this and
based on like who my audience was and
then i realized like you can actually do
research and there's seo and all the
stuff that goes behind it and then i was
like okay you know some of the things
they were talking about yesterday well
what am i competitors doing what videos
are they making that are successful so i
decided hey i'm going to research some
of these videos and i'm going to do
those same exact videos but i'm going to
do it in my way in my teaching style and
i'm going to put my own spin on it and
when i started really getting a little
bit more purposeful with the content
that i was making i noticed that that
was starting to drive views that was
starting to drive subscribers because i
was taking content that i knew would be
popular and would be good for my
audience and i was putting it in my
voice in my story and i was sharing that
with my audience and it was resonating
with them because obviously you know on
my other competitors channels with who
had success you know it was resonating
with with their audience and so i
started making those videos and pushing
out and just really paying attention to
the youtube analytics being like this
video did good why did this do good let
me do more of that this video didn't do
good why not let me not do that so i
really started paying attention to what
youtube was telling me to do versus not
do and that made a huge difference in my
channel yeah and nicole you've
experienced this as well how much
research are you doing in the types of
videos because your videos are so
specific to the woman you are trying to
reach
that's a really good question so we do
still do a lot of research around the
video topics and and it has become more
niche over time so you know i talk about
really embod like living my life and
picking topics that are aligned with
what i'm going through in this stage and
then researching and saying where can i
like hone in and where is there a space
for me but i want to touch on this
because it's something you taught me an
inner circle and that was sometimes the
video topic ideas that are going to like
blast you off into the next level are
the ones that are super simple and
you're not even thinking about because
it's right in front of your face so like
how to burp your baby was one that i
thought like everybody knows how to burp
their baby but you're like no this is so
basic and people are actually we did the
research created that video and it's one
of my most popular videos so sometimes
we're too close to it and it's really
helpful to have community say actually
this is a good one roll with it
oh yeah i remember that time too you're
like doesn't everyone know i'm like no i
remember when i had a baby i was like
trying to figure out what do you do how
do you do this and it was all the things
so i'm so excited that um that yeah
research is such a huge part of how you
do this entire process rather than just
willy-nilly making videos that you think
you should be making now this was really
good too nicole you said if you want to
make youtube sustainable make content
for you first and then your audience
break that down because
i'm sure people probably feel that like
well of course i'm going to make content
that i want to make but over time people
start asking for certain things that
could be outside of the wheelhouse of
what you were actually committed to so
talk about this a little bit and how
that has helped you get to a hundred
thousand
so very true so yeah you know a lot of
the times we
we hit you know maybe semi-viral videos
or you know things that start to take
off and we're like okay let's continue
down this train
but
what i found is that there are chapters
and phases in my life so as my kids have
grown i wouldn't always be making videos
about tummy time although i did do a
series you know and it's like okay my
kids are in a different stage let's
research and see what could work in the
phase we're in now because that's what
we're living we're playing we're doing
different activities so it aligns with
my life it's what i'm doing on a
day-to-day basis where can i capitalize
on youtube in the space i'm at in the
chapter i'm in in my actual life as
opposed to trying to
be in a space that worked at one point
but isn't necessarily aligned with how
i'm living in this moment yeah and
lauren you've actually implemented this
as well on your channel um even with the
the demographic the psychographic of
who's even watching your videos so talk
a little bit about how it really is
about making sustainable content that
you want to make not necessarily
everything your audience wants
yeah i mean in the beginning i in the
beginning uh you know because i had a
background in teaching guitar i said you
know when i started my channel i was
like i know i want to teach guitar and
who do i want to teach i want to teach
the people that i actually like teaching
so i thought about my own personal
experience as a guitar teacher and i
said you know what the favorite people
who i used to teach that it was like i
was surprised they were paying me money
to teach them because it was so much fun
so it was always people over the age of
50 all my older students and i
absolutely loved it so i said you know
what i'm just gonna focus my channel on
older students and of course obviously
i'm gonna i'm gonna attract other people
who are younger but all the music that i
was doing it's the music i like too i
actually really like you know the led
zeppelin the neil young and all the the
older stuff the beatles i got my beatles
my george harrison guitar back here but
that was the music i really loved doing
and that's what i was passionate about
and i think that's why i got along with
that generation so i just said you know
what i'm gonna focus a lot of like my
really specific song content on this
audience and i'm gonna go wider on some
of the broader topics like strumming how
to hold a guitar like all those basic
things but my focus was really on that
older demographic the music they love
but also the music i love because then
it makes it more enjoyable for me too
hey we're gonna get right back into
today's featured content but i wanted to
let you know about a free five-day
youtube challenge we have coming up in
just a few days we're hosting this free
five-day challenge that you can register
at tube1kchallenge.com
and during this challenge you're going
to get five free trainings and learn how
to get to your first 1000 subscribers
and earn your first 1 000 and beyond on
youtube you're gonna get the latest
strategies and all that you need to know
about starting and growing your youtube
channel right now this year so if that
sounds like it's right for you i want to
encourage you to sign up at
tube1kchallenge.com alright let's get
back into the featured content
and i love that you both said it really
is about the seasons like it also it's
about the people you want to reach but
also you have to have a passion for the
things you're creating we're not just
monkeys on a wheel you know we really
want to be making good monkeys on a
wheel okay we'll go with it we want to
make good content but we also want to
love the content that we're making now
both of you are incredibly focused women
both of you have uh careers around your
youtube channels you're not just making
youtube content both of you are running
these other businesses around what
you're doing and lauren's point was to
stay consistent create a schedule and
i'm like speaking to me i love that so
lauren how important is it to you to
stay consistent and doing that by
keeping a schedule
yeah i think my biggest downfall in the
beginning is that i wasn't consistent
you know i went back and i looked and i
was definitely not posting consistently
at all like the first couple years that
i was on on youtube because i had other
stuff you know i had a business you know
you have family life and all these other
things and then once i got consistent
about my schedule as to
i do a lot of batch recording so i'm
like okay i gotta film because i do two
videos every week and i'm like okay i'm
gonna sit down and i'm gonna film over
the next couple days all my content for
like the next month and then we go into
the editing process so for me it was
really important to schedule in time to
say hey this is when i'm gonna sit down
this is when i'm gonna do my content and
obviously before that point i had
researched and printed out and done all
of my organization work for how i'm
going to film these what songs i'm going
to do what lessons i'm going to do and
then obviously there's the day for the
production and the recording and then
after that it's the editing because i
found when i was trying to do like one
video a week every i always felt like
that like the monkey on the wheel as you
say you know i always felt like i was
chasing
that next video and i was it was very
stressful for me so i decrease that
stress by saying you know i'm just gonna
try and record all my videos in one day
and then i'm gonna edit them out and
that helped just relieve a lot of stress
for me and if something came up in life
that was okay because like i already
have recorded all the content i just
needed to edit it and and that helps so
much so if you don't have a schedule yet
just pick one day a week that you're
gonna commit to your channel and it
makes a huge difference
yeah and nicole i'm sure so many people
can relate to you know just your seasons
of life i don't think anyone comes to
youtube and says you know what i have
nothing to do i should start a youtube
channel no they're coming to youtube and
they're like i'm already an entrepreneur
i'm already you know running a family
i'm you know doing all the things
and i also want to do youtube that was
where you came in the and i also want to
do youtube so talk about what does your
schedule look like now in creating your
content how important is it to have a
schedule around what you're creating
it's a really good question so i'm i'm
slightly different i will say i started
with a schedule and it was really
important to me to get into a groove
initially um but being a mama to two
young ones my youngest one is 10 months
now and having a husband who's also an
entrepreneur there's a lot of give and
take and flexibility and so sticking to
a specific schedule has been a bit
challenging but i'm five years in now
and i just know that i'm committed and
if you go back and you look at my
youtube channel i'm still consistent i
still get the content out so i trust
myself that if it means i gotta film at
10 o'clock at night or on a day i wasn't
planning like i will get it done but it
was important to have structure around
me in the beginning to get into that
routine and have it be muscle memory
before i could say all right we're in a
season where we need more flexibility
you can be adaptable and i know that
you're just committed to this mission
you're going to figure it out oh that's
really good too yeah it changes as you
get more comfortable in front of the
camera as you get more comfortable and
like you said just being committed to
making the content the i will until i
will get this done i will figure this
out uh so number seven is nicole you
said there will be sharp ups and sharp
downs in this journey i think people
need to hear that i think that you know
especially when you're at a conference
like this and you're seeing some amazing
successful women like you two it's like
dang how did they get there it must have
been just luck right it's all just luck
so uh talk about those sharp ups and
those sharp downs on the journey nicole
yeah this has been huge for me because
it's so easy to get stuck in the very
moment or like that 30-day
stats right where it's like oh things
look down you know your subscriber
counts down your views are down and
especially in the beginning it's easy to
become discouraged with that and think
like okay well nothing i'm doing is
working should i just call it like this
clearly isn't working out for me and i
had a moment about a year ago where i
was going through that was like month
after month i couldn't figure out how to
get things back on track i just seemed
to be in this slide and then i did
myself a favor and i clicked lifetime on
our stats right where it breaks down
like your stats over your entire
lifetime and at that time it had been
about four years on youtube
and it was this beautiful moment this
epiphany of like it is up and down on
the way up when you pan out you see that
your trajectory is in fact heading in
the right direction you are moving you
are making gains but if you zoom in you
will see this
on your statistics it looks up it looks
down and in the moment when things are
sliding it just feels like everything is
falling apart but i want you to be able
to pan out and look at the big vision
and if you're just starting can you
trust that this is a minor dip and
otherwise upward trend so just staying
committed to your mission and your
vision and keep moving yeah wow what a
great insight to actually pan out and
see the whole picture uh we did that
here at think media you know about a
year
two years ago now we were in a downward
slump and we were like man what is
happening and then we pulled out the
numbers and we're like oh actually we're
doing just fine it's okay it just this
is kind of the cycle of life there are
there's spring there's summer there's
winter and there's fall how about you
lauren have you experienced kind of
those big ups those big downs in this
journey even just as an entrepreneur
building businesses and trying to build
your youtube channel at the same time
yeah i think that's i think that's just
the cycle of life there's there's highs
and there's lows and i remember
specifically um after you know the first
kind of covet after the shutdowns you
know everyone was home so everyone was
watching youtube everyone was all of a
sudden learning trying to learn guitar
so you know everything was really up in
you know march april may of 2020 i think
for a lot of youtubers and my adsense
was like really killing it at that point
and then i remember i posted in in the
vra you know facebook group and i i
think it was august it was this time of
year because august is summer this is
kind of like the slow time of year in
general for like music lessons even for
a brick and mortar business and i
remember being really disappointed i was
like man i was like it's doing so well
and now everyone's outside it's not it's
not going so great i remember being like
really down on myself and being like
that was it that was like that was like
my ride was was right there uh and then
it was just the cycle the fall came
around and you know christmas season
people get new guitars and stuff and
then all of a sudden everything shot
back up again so i think it's also
understanding the cycle of your business
so i know as a music teacher summer
tends to be that downward slump anyway
so i should expect things to pick up you
know as we get closer to christmas new
year's etc yeah and man i that was so
poignant what you said as a business
owner as a youtuber you should just know
that it's not always going to be up that
there's going to be ups there's going to
be downs because there's seasons to
business there's a reason that there is
an entire black friday sale crazy
christmas shopping all of those things
in actual retail stores because they are
anticipating that you're gonna buy stuff
for christmas whereas in the summer
there's not as much so it's really great
inside ladies all right we're going to
get into some bonus
uh points that you guys have lauren had
a great insight which was interact with
your audience and build community how
important has that been on your journey
to 100 000 lauren
yeah i mean it's it's so important i
think to connect with people and that's
why you know i'm here in the conference
i'm here in the chat and and talking
with people because people want to get
to know you and you know reaching out
just responding to those comments the
biggest thing that i get from a lot of
people even people who go and buy my
guitar course they send me emails all
the time like i was so impressed that
you respond to every single comment that
or that i actually got a response from
you on a comment they said that really
impressed me and that's what actually
made me go and purchase your product so
make sure to reach out get those
connections you know i have a private
facebook group but i do have like a free
facebook group and i'm in there i'm
talking to people and you know we're
sharing stuff about guitar but you know
when i went to iceland in july i'm
sharing my journey what i'm doing in in
life with people and they're so excited
to hear about that they want to be a
part of your life and get to know you so
don't be afraid to share other parts of
yourself with your audience it's going
to make that connection stronger yeah
nicole you've really experienced um by
being so in tune with your community
these amazing opportunities to be able
to create other products for them high
level products masterminds being able to
go deeper in exactly what they want
nicole is a product on how to feed your
baby i mean you wouldn't know that
nicole unless you were really deep in
your community how has this experience
allowed you by being in community how
did you get those ah-has to know i need
to create this for her next how did you
follow that journey
i love that question yeah it you know
it's a lot of what lauren said in just
building relationship with people you
know so inviting them into other spaces
off of youtube so whether it's an email
i have people respond to emails that go
out and it's just been this journey of
building relationships and understanding
what other women other mamas are walking
through and it's been huge for me in
terms of like what what would benefit my
community what should i create next and
being in conversation with them and also
allowing myself to evolve you know the
products and the things that i am
offering as eye of all and as my
community evolves too so relationship
building responding to comments inviting
them into your world being open to share
more of who you are and the journey
you're on has been ginormous in in my
path to building a business yeah and i
want to just make it very clear neither
of you have like teams of 20 around you
answering all your comments and sending
your emails is that correct lauren this
is you one on one in your community
right
yes yes i mean in the beginning i have
some some help now because it is getting
but i'm still in there like i'm still in
there all those personal technical
questions that's me
and you know a lot of times if people
send me emails it's me i'm it's still in
the trenches a lot only because i love
hearing from the community because they
tell me what they want lauren can you do
a video on this and i'm like you know
what that's actually a really good idea
and i did a video recently on a
suggestion that someone had made and it
was like one of my top videos so listen
to your audience that's the point of
interaction because that i i don't do a
lot of research anymore because people
just keep telling me what they want me
to do my content on so be in there
interact listen
that is amazing and exactly the point i
wanted to make was that it is i make it
a point to make sure that i am still
engaged with our community because when
you start losing touch you'll see
creators like this they start to lose
touch with their actual audience and
they start creating other content and
then they're like why isn't it working
because they have to be actively engaged
because this is the community you get to
create i mean this is how i look at it
as you just heard my story
uh that i wanted to be a people people
pleaser now it's almost it's the
complete opposite now i'm like i only
want to be around people that i like
like i want to be in community with
people that get what i'm doing and geek
out about the things that i'm doing and
it's so much fun and lastly you know uh
sean said it last night i thought it was
so great and i want nicole to end with
this but he said you know it's not like
you can take the silver play button to
the bank i know that both of you have
reached over 100 000 subscribers you
both have those silver play buttons in
the background you've reached this
milestone on youtube but really you wake
up the next day and you're still the
same girl right but nicole had such a
great point i want to end on this one
she said you will be better for this
journey nicole close this out by telling
us a little bit about why that was
something that helped you on your
journey to one hundred thousand
yeah you know
it's like it's beyond the numbers it's
beyond the views
it's beyond
everything that the accolades and the
awards it's like who do you want to be
on the other side of this i've gained so
much more intangible things like the
skill sets my ability to communicate my
ability to connect with other women who
are
in motherhood and going through the same
things that i am i i'm just a completely
different woman than when i started five
years ago and i wouldn't trade the ups
and the downs or this path to be here
for anything you know it's like i love
the silver play button i love what i've
created but ultimately this is the
legacy of me being courageous me trying
new things me following my soul and what
lights me up and and having an impact
and so
no matter what numbers you reach what
accolades you have brand deals
sponsorships it's all beautiful it's all
the cherry on top
but you can't lose by starting this you
will be better on the other side of this
journey um wow thank you so much for
that nicole and i so feel that in
exactly what you're creating and what
lauren's creating i want to thank both
of you um just for being women who said
yes for stepping up stepping out
grabbing the camera pressing record
being leaders in your community being uh
so gracious with your time today to come
on and share a little bit about your
experience i know both of you are very
focused women and so just giving your
time to us today at this conference is a
huge blessing so thank you for being
leaders i'm so glad that we're connected
i love that we're friends also in real
life um because it brings me so much joy
so lauren where can they go if people
want to find out more and follow your
journey obviously you're inside of video
ranking academy obviously you're here at
the conference but if they want to
connect with you where can they go
yeah i mean i'm on pretty active on
instagram at the lauren bateman
and my website is laurenbateman.com
that's my guitar teaching website so you
can always contact me through the
contact form there
amazing and nicole where can they go if
they want to go deeper with you
i am nicole amber on facebook instagram
and youtube so and my website is also
nicoleamber.com
awesome well hey share your aha moment
in the chat below give it up round of
applause for lauren and for nicole thank
you ladies for your time today
well i hope that that interview was
encouraging to you hearing real stories
like that from lauren and nicole they
really inspire me to want to get out
there and create more content and to
affect people in the communities that i
want to be engaged in i loved so much
about hearing their stories about how
they got to where they are today and
even what's next for them it's so
encouraging to see two powerful content
creators doing what they love and making
an impact in the world well i want to
say thank you to all of you who have
subscribed to this podcast our podcast
is growing right now on youtube on
spotify on apple and so thank you so
much for being a part of this think
media family and when you're over on
apple if you can rate and review the
podcast it helps us to get this content
out to more people who are aspiring
youtubers people who want to grow their
influence using the power of video so if
you want to leave that over there you
might be featured on an upcoming episode
and i want to ask you a favor can you
share this podcast with a friend maybe
you know someone who wants to become a
youtuber maybe you personally know
people in your life who should be doing
youtube i have people in my life every
day that i'm asking when are you
starting your youtube channel maybe you
have people like that as well so i would
encourage you to send this podcast to a
friend and you can always share our
podcast on social media and you can tag
us at official think media and we'll
share that out with our community as
well well thank you so much for
listening to this episode i hope you got
a ton of value and i cannot wait to see
you in another episode i'll see you soon